so the first pixel watch was bad but you
can't skip the first gen you just kind
of have to give it your best shot and
then what you learn you put into the
second gen and that's when we really
judge you and so even though it looks
almost exactly the same my hot take is
that the pixel Watch 2 is actually good
now so they gave it an updated quad core
processor which yeah makes it a bit
zippier around the user interface but
more importantly it's more efficient and
substantially improves battery life so
I'm now getting over 24 hours per charge
with the oon display on by default it
also charges much faster and on the back
you've gone from one to five heart rate
sensors so that's for much better heart
rate detection during heavy activity so
I did a workout with both the Apple
watch Ultra and the pixel Watch 2 on at
the same time and on the pixel watch you
literally get a new heart rate reading
every second which is super helpful for
stuff like hit workouts when you need to
wait till your heart rate drops to a
certain number before starting the next
thing it's so much better the only real
downside being that it uses a different
charger from last year so it's
incompatible with that but it's got the
same Sleek design and the same price not
bad anymore